bioenergy refers to power that is
generated from organic matter known as
biomass we heard earlier in the
programme that shell is planning a
biofuel plant in singapore in part to
lower its emissions
and if we look at electricity being
generated in britain right now
we can see
seven percent of that is coming from
biomass most of which is from burning
wood chips it is officially designated
as renewable because those wood chips
come from sustainable plantations so how
big a role should biofuels play in the
transition to a low carbon economy uh
george this is your topic let's put that
question to you first
i think the role should be about zero
it's an outrageous scam and so if you
look at a situation like drax they
appear to have lower carbon emissions
because of a carbon accounting
convention which says that you don't
count carbon dioxide produced from
burning mashed up trees because one day
trees will grow back to replace the ones
you've mashed up well the one day is the
crucial issue it could take decades to
absorb that carbon which you've just
released and we don't have advocates we
need to front load our environmental
action they're doing exactly the
opposite what we're seeing is a massive
new wave of forest destruction
caused by this supposedly green
technique of burning biomass and we're
seeing in some cases old growth forests
in europe and in north america being
failed to be turned into wood chip and
burnt is an absolute disgrace and it
needs to stop
julie biomass is classified as a
renewable fuel
is it clean or is it dirty as
george has described
um biomass can make a useful
contribution i think we know we have a
lot of commercial forestry in the uk
that forestry needs to be thinned there
are trees um which are not fit for
producing uh you know for using in in
construction and things
those thinnings can be used usefully for
biomass and indeed if we can use
appropriately produced biomass and i
agree with george it's really critical
that we ensure it is appropriately
produced if we can use that in the
future with carbon capture and storage
that can play
a small but significant role in uh in
giving us negative emissions and getting
helping us get to net zero but i agree
with him it does have to be extremely
carefully managed uh george
it's better than fossil fuels isn't it
no it isn't um forestry thinnings and
waste are always used as a trojan horse
to enable much bigger operations to go
ahead we sold the idea on the basis that
it'll be waste products used it's
invariably we end up with
fresh material being used entire forest
areas being cut down and fed into these
burners it's really disgraceful and the
whole idea of bio energy with carbon
capture and storage it is unicorn poo
it's a total pipe dream and honestly we
should just drop this nonsense and get
on with a genuinely clean energy
revolution based on renewables and i
think also fourth generation nuclear
ten seconds to get a final answer from
you then julia
um well appropriately used sustainable
biomass forms part of the climate change
committee's pathway to net zero
thank you very much very succinct and
julie king george monbiot thanks very
much indeed for joining us here on the
daily climate show this evening